hey cutie you looking for something
special you should take that cap off if
you didn't serve I served where we
Medevac from Fallujah that's in Iraq for
you boys you think you're tough huh I
mean I'm tough enough I guess why don't
we find out how tough I just I gotta get
to a party so maybe another time
it's a bachelorette party I love it here
great vibes
okay do we need to know who the
caretakers are anymore I think these
guys have been here for a while now
something strange about those guys
they're suspicious maybe you should
relax
[Applause]
screaming Is Not Gonna Keep Us Alive
listen to me and maybe that will
who is it why are they doing this I
don't know
we need to get prepared we gotta start
Gathering weapons all of you do anything
to survive and I mean anything
we have to do something drastic and we
need to do it now
you got no idea who we are and all we
want is what's inside that house
[Music]
just turn around and walk away I can't
do that I'm gonna kill you